seria
el médico teknon
un saludo muy cordial desde montreal a
todos nuestros oyentes e internautas que
nos siguen en este momento en directo a
través de facebook también por el canal
youtube y en nuestro sitio internet eres
en este punto o sea este es el programa
canadá en las américas café del castor
cibernético me acompañan en el estudio
paloma martínez leonardo gimeno y luis
laborda es un placer volver a verlos es
bienvenida tiempo varias semanas que sí
que estuve ausente y me encuentro que
bueno hoy es el día de la paz
internacional es el día internacional de
la paz decretado por naciones unidas
este 21 de septiembre también es el
inicio del otoño y tenemos es el día de
la primavera y del estudiante caramba
mira voz y hambre argentina el 21
nosotros nos íbamos de día
y acá
es el verano que termina el otoño que
está empezando pero está empezando
bastante mal a mi juicio si miramos esa
foto leonardo los turistas en la ciudad
de saskatoon en la provincia de
saskatchewan ayer y hoy estuvo nevando y
eso que todavía estamos medio en verano
entonces se es para anunciar tal vez un
poco el invierno que vamos a tener aquí
en canadá va a ser la nieve tal vez y
frío están anunciando frío como el año
pasado fríos extremos y que duran muchos
días seguidos ustedes acordarán de eso
no una parte de ese tiempo estuve
escapada bueno nosotros
ahora yo me acuerdo que eran días
seguidos por no decir semanas de un frío
intenso y lo que pasó el año pasado
particularmente lo que yo sufrí del año
pasado fue que empezó temprano el frío
intenso en diciembre hubieron dos
semanas de trabajo
de navidad y año nuevo justamente las
semanas de vacaciones
vamos con frío efectivamente lo que nos
vemos un chalet a pasar el día que hace
unos amigos el día en el 31 no primero
el primero de enero del 2018 y cuando
llegamos a esta zona un poco más al
norte pasando la parte de las vistas los
esquís y todo aquí en montreal de
temperatura hacia en 44 bajo cero más
temprano imagínate con el [ __ ]
fresquito yo me acuerdo hace hace muchos
años cuando hacían esos fríos me acuerdo
una escena que era de una película era
navidad o el 24 de diciembre íbamos a
algún lado y no no se podía arrancar el
auto la llave no entraba en la puerta
todavía me quedó grabado inclusive el
clima ha cambiado mucho en los últimos
años y en la última década sobre todo
pero en invierno no aparentemente se
está volviendo más frío y las
temperaturas extremas son más bajas y
efectivamente pero el recuerdo yo cuando
llegué que no hace tanto a mí me parece
que haya mucho más nivel ya que hay unos
años y ahora el año pasado hubo
muchísima nieve
la impresión que estamos volviendo a los
inviernos de los de los años yo recuerdo
hace cuatro o cinco años atrás que hubo
un récord de nieve fueron como cuatro
metros y medio de nieve durante el
invierno que se podía salir de la casa
que hay que empujarla
hubo casos de techos de escuelas que se
cayeron el peso porque digamos ciertas
estructuras están hechas para que la
nieve o resbaloso no la puede sacar en
ese caso los grandes edificios tienen
ejercicios planas entonces donde
acumulación pero digamos que bueno es
algo normal este es un país de invierno
no estamos hablando de huracanes y de
techos que vuelan y de esas cosas de
verano también porque el verano ha sido
generoso
empezó la temporada de quejas y les
colocamos que el verano ha sido bueno
en esta ausencia mía desde estas semanas
cuando yo me antes de irme de vacaciones
me acuerdo que había un sondeo donde se
hablaba ya de las elecciones aquí en la
provincia de québec y en aquel momento
daban
bastante el avance a la calle que es el
partido de coalición
el foro que coalición a venir que ve
quién que estaba primerísima los sondeos
y que ahora aparentemente hay como una
especie de empate o más queso el partido
liberal está como superando por la
primera posición en que estén igual el
primer ministro que es el candidato se
encarga trabajo puntos porque salió a
ser el día de ayer o anteayer diciendo
que el uno podía en una familia que ve
quién se podía comer con 75 dólar semana
según mi punto de vista fue que cuando
yo lo escuché a mí me pareció que no
dijo eso lo que dijo fue que él conocía
familias que vivían que pagaban 75 que
tenían solamente 75 dólares por un
adulto y dos adolescentes eso es lo que
especificó lo que sí podían comer claro
que se puede que podía que se puede
comer sí lo dijo pero sí pero dijo
además que eso era una desgracia porque
entonces no te alimentas bien claro y lo
que pasa es que se malinterpretó y las
redes sociales están alargando
como que él dijo que el que le quien se
podía comer la familia quebequense podía
comer con 75 dólares por semana
lo que notaba en esta campaña electoral
a golpes bajos no creo que hay golpes
bajos y creo también que la gente me
incluyo nos incluimos a veces tomamos
simplemente en la única la primera línea
que escuchamos y entonces el contexto se
pierde y creo que ahí es donde los
medios de comunicación jugamos un papel
importante porque hay que poner contexto
a cada cosa que es dicha entonces radio
canadá tiene una un segmento que se
encarga de hacer verificaciones de todo
lo que dicen los los políticos los
candidatos pero también un poco para
hacer para contrarrestarlas face news
las noticias falsas también son parte
del aire el cotidiano de este mes y
medio digamos en que se centro centraron
hoy a varios de valores ocupado y se
suponía que se no era un tema no
tendrían haber estado en la argolla más
bien la integración pero no
esta integración la que está dentro de
la discusión sino el debate desde un
punto de vista punitorio para mi gusto y
como lo expresado hablando con amigos
días pasados los partidos políticos han
tomado el tema de la inmigración como
rehén por qué no están debatiendo la
inmigración propiamente dicha no
explican de qué se trata la inmigración
no explican cuáles son los objetivos de
que tienen inmigración tanto en quebec
como en canadá tratan a la inmigración
como si fuera y hay un arroyo ya gustado
días pasados una expresión de su uso
frecuentemente en luego habla de
política de inmigración hablan de
política de importación de gente como si
se tratara de mercancía que no importa
porque le sirve y si no le sirve la
desecha me ha habido partidos políticos
ha habido un candidato específicamente
en los últimos días se ha referido a la
posibilidad de poder expulsar a gente
uno que es de la cac justamente
considerado un partido de derecha a 15 -
es decir hay cuatro partidos que están
luchando ahí en pugna
la derecha está el partido que ve que es
el partido independentista de québec
está tercero y bastante
lejos y el cuarto pues si en el
solidario
partido de izquierda está un poco más
lejos pero nada más comenta que ayer en
el último debate en francés el líder de
la cac del coalición ha de venir que ve
que se retractó de haber dicho que
expulsaría a gente lo cual me pareció
muy sorprendente porque durante semanas
ese fue ese fue parte de su discurso eso
fue parte de su diseño realidad no es
que se retractó sino que se disculpó de
haber dicho lo que dijo
expulsó a nadie lo di sólo sólo queremos
expulsar al partido quebequense dijo
desde el ganar diciendo le queremos
ganarle pero sí dijo que no es que el
tipo no es que él dijo que no lo había
dicho sino que reflexionó
un buen asesor o alguien informar porque
mara quitando vota al momento de venir
aquí el estudio acaba de editar una
entrevista que voy a publicar en el día
de hoy la persona entrevista se explica
muy muy simplemente y muy pocas palabras
que expulsar a alguien del país es un
resorte de gobierno
además el partido provincial no tiene ni
siquiera que meterse en el tema
no puede inferir no puede incidir en
nada es solamente un eslogan de campaña
e intentar hablar el voto de la gente
ubicada más a la derecha en el espectro
político de esta provincia y que hay que
aclarar que él dijo que iba a expulsar a
los inmigrantes es por dos motivos uno
que no hablaran francés y después número
dolores si no eran capaces de dar un
examen sobre cuáles eran los valores de
la sociedad quebequense lo que los hizo
mucho cuestionamiento cuáles son los
valores de una sociedad entera se
estamos hablando de 8 millones de
personas y seguramente que los valores
son muy diversos
yo creo que es como se llama el
dirigente s
france telecom luego bueno creo que esta
es su suba dicen que es su oportunidad
pues después no se va a presentar
aparentemente de nuevo ya perdió unas
elecciones anteriores bueno entonces va
a estar entre la cac y ya está en los
últimos 48 horas los civiles se han
recuperado bastante terreno
aparentemente están emparejados con la
cac en algunos últimos sondeos aparecen
y algunas décimas por encima de lo que
es sorprendente o tal vez ya no es
sorprendente es pues el partido
quebequense independentista en su
plataforma la manera en que está
retrocediendo aquí en que no lo deseamos
a yo creo que lo comentábamos con paloma
en un momento yo estaba recorriendo la
grilla de candidatos del partido
quebequense buscando alguien que
pudiéramos entrevistar para conocer la
posición de ese partido porque hemos
hecho otras entrevistas hemos tenido
invitados aquí en el estudio para que
nos hablarán de la propuesta de cada uno
de esos partidos nos falta todo el
partido quebequense y a mí me sorprendió
las figuras que aparecen en esa iglesia
andy data si parecen extraídos de un
museo realmente ese partido no solamente
no se ha modernizado en sus propuestas y
en sus objetivos y en su gente sino ni
siquiera quien quienes lo integran y la
diversidad como está ahí lo diversa es
la diversidad es prácticamente cero y es
increíble porque yo conozco un montón de
inmigrantes que estarían por una posible
digamos como plan alguno de los planes
profundos del partido quebequense
yo conozco un montón de inmigrantes que
están de acuerdo
o sea básicamente en el proyecto como
tal lo pasa es que no se le da cabida
tampoco los inmigrantes no hay que
olvidar que durante los otros referendos
las comunidades inmigrantes que creían
en una independencia de québec
participar
pero yo creo que eso ya no se da de la
misma manera tampoco y además como ya lo
venía diciendo un demógrafo hace unos
años el la demografía juega en contra
del partido independentista en quebec y
es cierto entonces a la mayoría de los
inmigrantes que vienen ahora que ve que
son de países francófonos de áfrica y
eso pues son inmigrantes que vienen a
canadá también no vienen solo de todas
maneras y creo que hay que reconocerlo
de las cuatro formaciones principales no
sé si hay otras en realidad los cuatro
principales que participan en esto que
van a participar con alguna chance en
esta elección
quebec solidario es el único partido que
tiene representada en su grilla de
candidatos la diversidad de esta
sociedad los demás parecen no haberse
enterado todavía los demás hablan de
inmigración solamente cuando se viene
encima una campaña cuando les conviene
para lograr el apoyo de algún sector de
la sociedad el resto del año el resto
del periodo entre elecciones la
diversidad de nuestra sociedad no existe
y esto el uso para los medios de
comunicación un poco lo creo que paloma
hablo un poco de eso sobre el alcalde la
alcaldesa de montreal que había dicho
que que los inmigrantes justamente como
decía luis hace un momento no son
mercancía que los inmigrantes vienen
aquí no solamente a paliar la escasez de
mano de obra sino también a formar parte
de la sociedad el de formar parte del
tejido humano y esa es una de las cosas
que también vimos en los discursos de
mano más sé que es la una de las
portavoces de quebec solidario que justo
fue la única que dijo los inmigrantes
nos escogieron están aquí en quebec
porque quieren vivir aquí y que tienen y
son parte de la sociedad no solamente
vienen a hacer los trabajos
no queremos hacer vienen a ser parte de
entonces porque todos esos esas
declaraciones están saliendo a la vía
pública entonces me imagino que va a
tener un efecto también en el momento de
la votación y no hay que decir que
también el dirigente del partido liberal
también hizo mención de eso siempre más
la sociedad con completamente pues
siempre lo dijeron y los liberales creo
que tienen gente candidatos también de
otras comunidades hay un latinoamericano
que hubo entrevistas test y pocos
todavía viene ya viene la entrevista con
saúl polo que es uno de los de los
inmigrantes los latinoamericanos en las
candidaturas liberales
bueno pues muy bien las elecciones en la
provincia de québec son la próxima
semana el primero de octubre entonces
ahí va a haber vamos a saber que el que
venga a tener un nuevo un nuevo primer
ministro no sé si un nuevo partido o un
nuevo primer ministro pero va a ver la
novedad como fue en ontario hace poco
que eligieron
y por qué es el partido conservador de
derecha también de ontario y esta semana
también hay elecciones en la
aproximación y parece que ahí también
está muy reñido el partido conservador y
el partido liberal están muy muy muy
cerca el uno del otro a karam entonces
es es posible que los liberales pierdan
el poder aunque hay mucho debate con
respecto al bilingüismo es la única
provincia bilingüe de canadá segmento
oficialmente entonces hay mucho creo que
todo va a estar alrededor de la lengua
en esta en esta elección en nuevo
brunswick bueno y en américa latina ya
pasaron las elecciones no es decir
méxico fue el gran golpe esta vez hay 30
millones de personas que votaron por
lópez obrador eso es una cifra
extraordinaria y ya no hay más
elecciones
va a ser la elección del candidato
activa primero nos encuesta ya ha sido
excluido de la contienda y el candidato
que lo reemplazará bastante pocas
chances de llegar a esos niveles de
preferencia electoral
aunque ultimando tenido creación está
creciendo está creciendo se sabe no se
sabe es el candidato de lula elegido por
el partido de los trabajadores decir que
enfrenta una situación preelectoral
realmente muy complicada porque no
solamente lula fue excluído el candidato
con más chance que el nombre se me está
escapando en este momento el candidato
del partido militar fue apuñalado en un
acto de campaña con jota
si el nombre es la derecha a la derecha
fuerte si así pero bueno ese es el que
iba liderando las encuestas una vez que
que lula fue excluido y el electrodo
para sí estar en el limbo nadie sabe qué
va a pasar en las elecciones en ese país
que son también dentro muy pocos días
cuando pienso en brasil que hasta hace
pocos años era considerado el gran motor
económico de américa latina y del mundo
un país de entre considerado entre los
cinco más grandes emergentes al lado de
india por ejemplo pero si están
retrocediendo y deciden bueno en fin hay
otras
hay otras tendencias que se están
manifestando en brasil- sonaron la bolsa
no fue él el que fue acuchillada sí sí
sí sí sí sí fue
él fue apuñalado fue apuñalado en un
acto de agresión de produjo elecciones y
lesiones mucho más complicadas que se
siguió en un primer momento él sigue
siendo candidato sí pero sigue
hospitalizado y ha sido sometido a una
segunda intervención quirúrgica que ha
sido que pueda quedar fuera de la
contienda electoral
bueno muy bien entonces ella sí que
tengo saludos en realidad gente empiece
a sintonizar julio ernesto franco
edición saludos de colombia rené
betancourt saludos al equipo 6 desde
quiport nueva jersey en estados unidos
echeverría también dice saludo amigos
así que es algo muy bien bueno en el
programa para todos aquellos no lo vamos
a hacer ahora desde acá pero los que
pueden entrar a nuestro sitio el cygnet
punto o sea vamos a presentarle
especial de música es un tema que se
refiere a los grandes premios polaris
canadienses a la música popular
canadiense estos son los premios 2018
paloma vos hiciste un reportaje bien
particular sobre no sólo el gran ganador
de este premio polaris 2018 que hay que
decir que el año pasado fue una
colombiana canadiense de beso hablamos
mucho me acuerdo sino que también existe
un retrato un poco de los todos los
finalistas entonces hay una variedad de
música es increíble y ahora había 10
álbumes nominados al gran premio polaris
2018 que es uno de los problemas más de
estándares más prestigiosos aquí en
canadá y la gala de este evento lo lara
presentó si vice que es un radio canadá
de la diana de la party les exactamente
que es un gran
como decir lo que apoya muchísimo toda
la música independiente canadiense
entonces entre los 10 álbumes nominados
había tanto música clásica como música
pop alternativo como música justamente
del gran ganador indígena que además es
un es un nombre que me pareció
extraordinario su camino porque se llama
le voy a decir el nombre se llama jeremy
thatcher de donde se es de nuevo bronze
29 bronce muy bien entonces él lo que
nos lo que explicaba al ganar el al
ganar el premio es que sentía un gran
orgullo porque por primera vez la música
porque lo que hace él es es un tenor
primero hay que decir tiene una
formación clásica de música clásica y lo
que hizo él además de ser tenores
musicólogo en tos fue hace una
investigación sobre todas las
grabaciones antiguas en los archivos de
nuevo bronze week fue a buscar los
sonidos de la música indígena de de hace
mucho tiempo las más son antiguas
grabaciones entonces grabé recuperó todo
eso y de alguna manera lo trabajó lo
inventó exactamente lo reinventó
con su música reinterpretó también los
cantos tradicionales de su nación de la
primera nación to be que first nations
de la que él es parte y bueno no les
digo el nombre del álbum porque de todas
maneras lo que es interesante es
escuchar lo que él hizo no exactamente
entonces me imagino que la gente que
vaya a nuestro sitio esperando se sintió
para encontrar la música de cada uno de
los intérpretes está increíble eso para
él para los que quieren escuchar
justamente la variación de la música
canadiense y verza la música y también
tienen para pasar todo un día entonces
con esa música es el reportaje preparado
por paloma martínez vamos entonces ahora
antes de antes de ir a los temas que
estamos destacando ahí tenemos muchísimo
mensaje
yo me olvidé de darles al principio
estamos aquí vamos entonces empecemos
paloma que tienes tengo
un comentario con respecto a un artículo
que escribimos que presentamos un
revolucionario tratamiento para la
escoliosis en montreal y julio pérez
dice saludos desde perú mi pequeño de 13
años tiene escoliosis severa
aquí no hay tratamientos ni operaciones
modernas ayúdenme con una esperanza para
este caso la desviación se originó por
una enfermedad genética nf1 sé que debe
ser un tratamiento costoso ese es el
problema entonces bueno comenta con
respecto a este nuevo tratamiento aquí
en canadá y claro como se sabe el ser el
sistema de salud canadiense es para los
canadienses viviendo en canadá
pero seguramente que puede altares de la
retina que ahora ya normas ya en el país
donde viven seguramente que están hay
otro tipo de tratamientos como
elaboraciones médicas no entonces acepta
en algún momento probablemente habrá yo
me acuerdo cuando entrevisté a un médico
de saskatchewan sobre el tema de la de
estos como se llama estos ataques cuando
tienes piletas de epilepsia él es de
algo en méxico cierto claro él está pero
no solamente en méxico
lo que ellos están aprendiendo con sus
investigaciones lo comparten con lo que
aprenden de investigaciones que se hacen
en méxico en brasil en colombia entonces
hay una red de ese tipo de cosas
seguramente están informados con otros
otros tipos de investigaciones de
enfermedades si louis continuando con la
temática médica para la asociación
médica canadiense con la legalización de
la marihuana el uso médico será
innecesario es el tema y hace comentario
al respecto alexandra hernández que dice
buenas tardes soy del salvador hemos
sido amenazados por pandillas tengo dos
niñas necesitamos ayuda para salir del
país no tiene nada que ver con el tema
y en este caso le respondemos lo mismo
que hacemos siempre que acuda a las
páginas de los organismos oficiales que
podrán que están en castellano o
directamente enlace en la embajada de
canadá en su país ambiente si leonardo
si aquí tengo un mensaje sobre el tema
recuperando sonrisas un programa de
dentistas canadienses para mujeres
marginales rosilita nos dice que bueno
que haya gente dice así soy una mujer de
41 años con un grave problema
he leído que hasta morir por las
infecciones y la verdad que tengo mucho
miedo y tengo un nieto que cuida de mi
hija que tiene 17 años y deseo poder
tener salud de mi boca ojalá pudiera
ayudar dios los bendiga y le decimos a
rosa que en realidad no sé de dónde
escribe que esto es específicamente para
gente para canadiense y yeste y esta
noticia partió de la base de un proyecto
especial hecho en toronto
así que si vive en toronto podría decir
que en hacerlo seguro si no vive en
toronto ahí nos hemos enterado porque
hay mucha gente que nos pide información
hay programas similares en muchos del
mundo así que si vive en centroamérica
seguramente tiene que haber suponemos
que en alguna clínica especializada o
quizás en la universidad que enseña a
este tipo de metía en las universidades
es cierto que hay prácticas
en los estudiantes de último año
entonces eso es ofrecen tales servicios
gratuitos ya donde se aclaró exactamente
así que probablemente puedan encontrar
algún tipo de solución en esta en este
tipo de instituciones acá hay un tema
sobre la policía montada de canadá que
abre sus puertas a los inmigrantes
escribe fabián forero que dice que
quiere ser parte de la policía montada
porque además además él es parte de la
policía nacional de colombia y quiere
por supuesto venir acá y pregunta cómo
hacer para adquirir más información
sobre esta propuesta
paloma si tengo aquí un comentario de
javier gonzález nungaray con respecto a
la casa exitosa de ballena mor boreal en
el ártico canadiense dice creo que la
casa realizada por los inuit es una
cacería consciente es decir
es medida no casan por cazar y la
cacería comercial es una cacería
desmedida un saludo a todos mis amigos
de radio canadá internacional en el
castor cibernético desde su taxi en
guadalajara muy bien siempre si no se
escucha lo cual es cierto lo que él dice
los inuit en ese sentido cuando cuando
matan causan una ballena les sirve todo
el año la crema más que está haciendo
referencia un artículo que escribimos y
que presentamos con imágenes parece que
tenían siete años este está esta ballena
en particular les había costado no ella
en particular ese tipo esta especie de
ballena es muy difícil de cazar entonces
durante siete años estuvieron preparando
es dos o tres comunidades que además
cuando lograron cazar la compartieron no
alarga demasiado todo el año pueden
estar comiendo esa carne que está
congelada y ahí mismo en el artículo
pueden hacer además delicias con la
grasa de ballena hacen también veladoras
etcétera entonces es muchísima utilidad
a diferencia de la casa industrial sea
parcial que pues tiran la mitad
tengo un mensaje muy corto que nos envía
maría isabel martín aguirre sobre el
tema macri propone que corte penal
internacional investiga viene fuera
macri es el presidente argentino uno de
los que deberá revalidar sus títulos en
año próximo y dice me apoyó desde mexico
los venezolanos merecen justicia que es
el mensaje de maría isabel martín
aguirre
leonardo aquí otro otro mensaje en este
caso con los resultados de las últimas
encuestas dan una amplia ventaja a lópez
obrador en mexico y flora obviamente si
antes de las elecciones y fernando vida
hernández dice lópez obrador
prácticamente ex presidente de la
republica mexicana no se equivocó
necesitarán de la honestidad dignidad y
trabajo de todos los mexicanos
respetando las diferencias y las
diferentes formas de pensar y por fin
están unidos en un objetivo
indispensable hacer méxico más grande
estar conscientes de la necesidad de
mantener una relación cordial con eeuu
pero también de dignidad y soberanía
recordar y nunca olvidar que somos
latinoamericanos y que nuestros hermanos
de centro y suramérica esperan lograr
fortaleza en la verdadera unión
latinoamericana necesita el mundo un
desarrollo más equitativo para lograr un
mayor nivel de humanización de nuestra
especie y algo al respecto contestaba
otra persona diciendo nuestro ex alcalde
será un buen amigo de canadá en estos
tiempos de racistas y anti todos
política de eeuu muy bien pues dos
comentarios sobre este tema te queda
paloma todavía hay algo si me queda a
uno comentando el la diverge el artículo
las divergencias entre el gobierno de
canadá y los movimientos sociales en
torno a venezuela y alberto dice lástima
las pocas intervenciones del primer
ministro de canadá si su papá estuviera
vivo le diría hijo qué estás haciendo no
te metás salud
no no para molestar a tu país vecino y
era un mensaje de alberto con respecto
al tema de divergencias entre el
gobierno de canadá y los movimientos
sociales en torno a venezuela gracias
albergue sobre el mismo tema yo tengo un
comentario que nos envía rodrigo viega
gamarra y cuervos que nos dice muy
objetivos y punto de los comentarios los
señores molina y antonio
deben ser dos personas que comentaron
nuestra página comentarios de otros
seguidores pero como para esos
comentarios aclaran la desinformación
que a veces a través de la prensa llega
a la opinión pública felicitaciones
producciones molina y antonio bueno yo
tengo acá un tema que es el bilingüismo
una vez una ventaja para niños con
autismo dicen investigadores canadienses
se escribe
mercedes y dice mi nombre es mercedes y
somos españoles pero vivimos en
inglaterra desde hace tres años mi hijo
tiene cuatro años y tiene autismo quería
preguntar si le hace una pregunta a otra
persona que escribió en nuestro sitio y
dice quería preguntarte si a tu hijo le
pasó como al mío porque estoy un poco
preocupado el caso es que él entiende
los dos idiomas con algunas dificultades
pero en general entiende los dos pero
veo que está avanzando mucho mejor y más
rápido en inglés que en español eso es
normal esto me hace plantearme si
deberíamos volver a españa para que el
mejore su español claro que no tengo
unos hijos bilingües trileros
y tienen empiezan lento con los dos y al
final se va despegando más en la lengua
que utilizan más la lengua o el inglés y
después el español viene si uno les
habla en español bien
la receta y es y no deja nunca de hablar
español en el contexto del área la casa
es el secreto exactamente louis tienes
algo más si acá tengo un mensaje sobre
canadá y su plan de inmigración 2018 que
nos envía a mercedes dice habla que su
esposo es cubano y que entró a canadá
caminando se presentó a las oficinas de
inmigración pidió refugio y que fueron
denegadas entró caminando sin que fueron
denegados los pedidos de refugio y que
se casaron en 2015 y que bueno está
intentando resolver su situación para
poder recibir legalmente a ambos aquí en
el país la misma respuesta de siempre
los organismos pertinentes pueden
ocuparse muchas cosas que nosotros del
tema leonardo el último si tengo aquí
tema canadienses habrían encontrado
medicamento para frenar la esclerosis
lateral amitrófica o enfermedad de lou
gehrig
francisco javier saucedo gutiérrez se
nos dice hola muchas gracias por la
información me parece magnífica y qué
buenos resultados por el esfuerzo de
todas estas pruebas mi padre tiene esa
enfermedad estaré agradecido de
información adicional y si es posible
anexarse a la siguiente frase es fácil
de investigación muchas gracias otra vez
en un caso con este caso al mensaje a
francisco es hay que contactarse con el
equipo de investigación que está
exactamente este tipo de avances para
ver si están necesitando gente para la
población
digamos que tratan para la investigación
exacto pues muy bien vas a marcar los
por favor leídos y nosotros vamos a ir
ahora a los programas que destaca cada
uno de nosotros esta semana vamos a
empezar con luiz que nos hablas de una
ciudad hermosa hay que decir que es una
para mi juicio es una de las ciudades
más hermosas más bonitas de canadá que
es halifax rodeada de agua no sé si
conociste
si por lo menos dos veces
y es una ciudad una de las más lindas
que conozco de canadá muy de paisaje y
también muy tranquila y estás hablando
hiciste una entrevista con alguien que
habla de inmigrantes y diversidad en
esta ciudad y que yo me acuerdo cuando
fuimos hace muchísimos años había
algunos inmigrantes pero había
dificultad en encontrar variedad de
diferentes tipos de inmigrantes para
poder hacer grandes programas bueno
según esteban eso está cambiando según
está entrevistada que concuerda ciento
por ciento con tus apreciaciones sobre
la ciudad
morada de halifax se llama magaly damas
y ella es profesora universitaria y
aparte integra un organismo que trabaja
con los latinoamericanos en particular
promoviendo la cultura latinoamericana y
mi intención al hablar con ella era
conocer la opinión de una persona del
común no hablar siempre de política de
inmigración o de promoción de alguna
región en particular o de alguna ciudad
en particular ella reside allí hace
muchos años después de haber habitado en
toronto primero
y de haber vuelto a su perú natal en el
internet no más tarde su marido recibe
una propuesta laboral se fueron a vivir
a halifax y ella está absolutamente
enamorada cuenta exactamente lo mismo
que vos acabas de decir cuando ella
llegó a halifax en el 2002 la diversidad
era prácticamente invisible ella define
muy bien a la provincia de nueva escocia
como una provincia blanca que es que fue
trazada en todo caso por los colonos
británicos que llegaron allí
principalmente a partir de los colonos
ingleses irlandeses y escoceses que
fueron los que construyeron la nueva
escocia que conocemos nosotros pero poco
a poco se ha ido sumando otras
poblaciones entre ellas la
latinoamericana y según magaly esto ha
ocurrido porque hay una decisión muy
clara de las autoridades que han puesto
en práctica distintas iniciativas
distintos programas que promueven la
radicación de nuevos presidentes bien
esta provincia que recordemos es
integrante de las provincias atlánticas
que son señaladas siempre como
provincias que expulsan población
en nueva escocia se ha propuesto retener
una de las políticas centrales de la
administración actuales estarían
logrando porque halifax en el último año
ha logrado incrementar su población en
12.000 personas es mucho para una ciudad
de 400 mil habitantes ha hecho muchísimo
y hay muchísimos jóvenes que están
llegando ella resalta por ejemplo el
tema del costo de la vivienda que sigue
siendo muy bajo
huber montes suaves montreal es ese
rescate al tema del costo de vivienda y
describe la ciudad como un lugar en el
que se puede cambiar a un paso rápido
pero no apurado
entonces que efectivamente es muy es es
una ciudad que ofrece una vida
interesante pero al mismo tiempo calma y
relajadas tienen tiempo para compartir
con los amigos donde se evitan los
grandes problemas de congestión de
tránsito que viven en las mayores
ciudades canadienses se puede ir de un
lugar al otro de la ciudad muy poco
minutos se puede tener una casa frente
al mar que el mal de oro lo señala
constantemente es un tal vez el icono de
el elemento más importante que determina
muchísimo la vida allí te invito a todos
los interesados a que vayan a las que
emitan páginas de servicios que hay de
ofertas muy concretas para ayudar a la
ubicación de personas o de familias
completas en esa provincia y los llevará
según sostiene ella a enamorarse y con
el mismo grado ya estoy yo ya estoy
enamorada yo me enamoré apenas llegue
vamos a hablar de lola una mexicanidad
musical dice paloma a la canadiense son
dos hermanas me pregunto si lola con dos
es porque son dos hermanos que querían
hacer referencia a dolores que es el
nombre de su abuela y que es el nombre
también de la de la señora de los
dolores' en méxico y que tienen que es
muy muy seguida por mucha gente entonces
quisieron ponerle el diminutivo del
dolor es es lola entonces pero buscar
había muchos proyectos que se llamaban
los lentos dijeron con doble a no va a
haber nada y son estas dos hermanas lex
valentín y nadie a valerie quin su
apellido es flores pero lo eliminan de
digamos de las de sus nombres de
escenario entonces son o son dos jóvenes
cuyos padres son de origen mexicano ella
y la miraron no y porque se pusieron kim
y en vez de queens
en realidad yo creo que era porque
tuvieron antes proyectos separados y
cada uno eligió su nombre artístico y
ahora están juntas y ya puede ser que
eso fue lo que yo entendí no tenían
tenían un proyecto juntas antes pero
tenían nombres de escenario y diferente
entonces después cuando se pusieron
juntas por eso decidieron no es lo que
dice el proyecto también era junta pero
con otra persona es decir nunca han
estado separadas musical entonces bueno
fíjate que lo que lo que me llamó la
atención a mí es que la música en la que
inspiran es la música de los años 70 y
80s en méxico y en américa la colina
están las cosas daniela romo también se
basan en gloria estefan y música que uno
podría considerar muy cursi pero que
ellas la adaptan a la el sonido
canadiense a la música alternativa
canadiense al pop latino canadiense
entonces en una cosa exactamente
entonces suena un poco 80 70s al mismo
tiempo muy moderno y bueno tienen además
muchas ganas de hacer ahora el proyecto
en español porque comenzaron en inglés
porque claro a su lengua nacieron en
toronto pero ahora quieren hacerlo volar
digamos en español y en esas están
presentaron un nuevo sencillo eres
varios nuevos sencillos en español y
bueno en esas están slo las son de
toronto no son de toronto donde palmas
son de mexico muy bien pero ellas
nacieron a cabo en méxico acá
muy bien entonces interesante para
escuchar lo que hicieron desde nuevo y
como como modificaron esa música
mexicana o latinoamericana y la
transforma
debe ser muy interesante entonces a los
que quieran escuchar esta entrevista y
la música del hola
en jersey nets punto seas leonardo que
presentas yo puntualmente bueno avances
y que ya está llegando a encontrar por
siempre hablamos de los avances
tecnológicos lo buscó en todo el mundo
que es lo que pasa y encuentro cosas que
se están haciendo afuera puntualmente en
este caso de hable esta es la tercera
vez de la lo que se viene en transmisión
de datos que es el live aid l
efe wifi sino live faiques y es la
transmisión de datos por las bombillas
de luz a poder poder traducir que es los
datos yo tengo una computadora voy a
tener un pequeño adaptador y voy a
enviar internet voy a enviar la señal de
internet de la luz directamente al
adaptador y viceversa para hacer hablo
down those de datos sobre salir gratis
no uno va a pagar su plan de internet la
diferencia es la cantidad y cientos de
veces más rápido potente más potente
para ese tipo de transmisión de datos
que en la que estamos a cuento eso lo
inventar en realidad el término sd
que fue en el 2011 es un investigador
europeo que encontró la posibilidad de
transmitir un día luz
las ondas o las ondas con las que hoy
recibimos el wifi los pases que están en
desarrollo
desde el 2011 que salió el concepto que
se abre el concepto en el 2014 empresas
grandes como philips y de otras
asiáticas compran parte del proyecto
para empezar a desarrollarlo bueno ahora
la ucam está nacional está haciendo
varias desarrollos o no digamos tienen
tienen como la licencia para el
desarrollo de ciertas acciones dentro de
la universidad de la universidad y está
ojo no solamente entre la universidad
ellos pueden comercializar la hacia
afuera lo que están haciendo son
proyectos de ver cuáles son las
utilidades de este tipo de conexión que
pueden brindarle a la gente y obviamente
en realidad él
el artículo está publicado sale mañana
van a ver la cantidad de cosas que se
puede hacer es increíble es increíble y
bless la única cuestión digamos un pro
importantísimo es muy difícil de hackear
porque no tiene acceso desde afuera
como hasta que descubran cómo y la en la
contra es que se circunscribe el lugar
que estamos porque la luz no pasa el
auto cual al otro cuarto pero al
proyecto ya en ciudades donde las
lámparas afuera que emitan ese tipo de
información para que uno puede ir
caminando y tenga es lo que te iba a
decir se pueden conectar las lámparas
así que va a ser mucho más accesible
asiento muchos van a ser siderales así
que bueno ese proyecto y la cama en la
universidad en montreal está algunos
desarrollos que tienen que ver con el
life
acabo de leer de que se acabe se hizo
una presentación
de estos famosos teléfonos ahora que no
sé cuántos salen de caro si queda locura
y que el sitio fue hackeado y un chico
joven logró coronar con 500 teléfonos
por un dólar caso 1 cuando vale que es
imposible de hackear yo creo que eso no
existe esa palabra no no es verdad lo
pases que va a tener que estar
físicamente a lo tuyo para hackear lo a
veces tu mejor amigo bueno yo tengo el
tema sobre un futuro que dice el título
de una campaña mejor dicho de un informe
de unicef canadá conversamos con david
morley que es el presidente y director
ejecutivo de unicef acaban de lanzar
este informe sobre el futuro robado a
los jóvenes sin escolarizar es decir
jóvenes que no acceden a sobre todo la
escuela secundaria y es un fenómeno que
se está dando muchísimo en los países
sobre todo africanos y en algunos países
y árabes y que se debe a conflictos que
existen en esos países pero sobre todo
la pobreza y el hoy lo interesante de
este de este informe que es un informe
mundial de unicef es que sólo hay dos
países citados dos países de américa
latina citados en este informe con
problemas extremos de pobreza y con
muchísimos niños justamente que no
acceden a la secundaria sobre todo y que
se honduras y en guatemala son los dos
países
bueno son los los países más pobres del
hemisferio no y lo interesante que
destaca también el director de unicef
canadá es esto que pasó en la en la
ciudad en quebec este año con la reunión
del g7 donde canadá
y obtuvo 400 millones de dólares puso
canadá pero con otros países del g7 para
la educación de las niñas en los países
estos que están afectados por conflictos
entonces en este sentido es un paso
importante que dio canadá pero que no es
suficiente porque además lo que él
reclama un poco y reclama unicef es la
falta de presupuesto que tienen los
estados para educar a sus propios niños
entonces da como ejemplo de donde se
mejoró muchísimo la educación el acceso
a la educación de los niños en el mundo
da brasil brasil desde hace unos años
nomás decena de años viene aumentando el
presupuesto para los niños para la
educación y se están viendo los
resultados hoy entonces es un ejemplo a
seguir
bueno esto y más en la entrevista
entonces con unicef canadá entonces
bueno ya nos vamos ya no hay nada más
que ya se fue todo el tío este de la
nación electrónica tal vez el domingo
sin candidatos de nuevo explica quién es
el candidato de nuevo a los premios
latin awards canadá 2018 en nuestro
sitio a votar verde tenemos ahí hemos
puesto ya en el facebook las direcciones
para que faltan a votar no solamente el
voto de la gente lo que cuenta también
tiene un tribunal que es el que decide
finalmente pero 40 tan bueno así que
este programa pues si no les gusta igual
y pueden votar desde cualquier parte del
mundo por lo que entendía el programa
bueno muy bien eso es todo nos vamos y
será hasta la próxima semana muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros